[Musique]
c'est le seul sénateur de la république
en marge des yvelines martin lévriers
bonjour aujourd'hui pour ce café
politique je vous en prie aussi d'aller
vous nous allons parler de vous de vos
engagements et puis forcément aussi un
petit peu de certains dossiers
politiques vous êtes en poste depuis
2000 17 et vous avez donc empêché les
républicains de faire le grand chelem
dans le département des yvelines lors
des dernières élections
vous n'êtes pas trop seul à ce poste
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines je suis
seul à ce poste dans les yvelines au nom
de la république en marche mais nous
sommes quand même six sénateurs une mais
il est vrai que ces deux départements
est très grand pour un seul sénateur
mais passionnant est-ce que ça a été
difficile pour vous d'obtenir ce poste
de sénateur on sait le département est
très ancrée à droite faire passer vos
idées c'est un peu plus compliqué
c'était beaucoup plus difficile parce
que l'élection l'élection des sénateurs
et est fondée sur sur une élection qui
est qui est celle des grands électeurs
qui ont été élus il ya trois ans donc
absolument pas sur la sur la vague la
république en marche mais sur une vague
bleue
donc le combat était obligatoirement
apprend plus confrontés au président et
je vous rappelle à dix listes dont
certaines se revendiquer du même
mouvement que moi et pas simplement
qu'effectivement ça a été une grand
pagne d'abord très très courte difficile
âpre mais passionnante qui a donné un
très bon résultat puisque finalement sur
cette élection montre qu'on est la
deuxième force du département très
largement
vous êtes né en 62 à tour vous êtes
arrivé sur versailles dans un cadre
professionnel vous faisiez secrétaire
général de notre dame blanche en lycée
d'enseignement général technologique et
professionnel sous contrat pourquoi
cette arrivée sur le département
c'était purement professionnel c'est
exclusivement professionnel au départ
absolument
département vous a plu et le département
m'a emballé j'y suis resté j'y suis très
heureux une ville formidable pour elle
et ses enfants département merveilleux à
visiter est ce pour se promener pour
découvrir des innovations tous les côtés
une culture remarquable donc oui bien
sûr je suis versailles et maintenant je
suis yvelinois même dame
en tout cas vous n'êtes pas un
professionnel de la politique voilà
alors arrivé dans le département où dix
ans je vais m'installer ici pour faire
une carrière politique pas du tout la
preuve c'est que j'ai mis trente ans à
28 ans à me relancer entre guillements
très haut en politique puisque j'ai
quand même tout abordé donner un petit
peu la politique au niveau local en
touraine au gt où je me suis présenté à
une élection municipale sous quelle
étiquette il pas d'étiquette métaux
divers droite plutôt que d être le maire
en place était cds et j'ai voulu le
soutenir
on a été malheureusement pas
malheureusement battu voilà donc mais
c'était déjà une première approche de la
politique m'a toujours passionné mais
après vous avez votre vie privée qui
prend le pas votre nouvelle vie
professionnelle qui vous occupe beaucoup
et puis à un moment vous reposer ces
questions là et ils vous font c'est la
priorité dans votre cadre professionnel
c'était d'agir dans un domaine social
l'éducation d'insertion point de départ
social j'ai toujours voulu que mes
valeurs soient prioritaires sur 20 soit
en adéquation avec mon travail donc mon
premier travail ça a été dans une maison
de retraite une ré sont des retraites
mais qui était une fondation dont
l'objet était d'accueillir les personnes
âgées pauvres
et puis mon deuxième en mon deuxième
engagement qui a duré 28 ans était au
sein d'une association scolaire
effectivement donc tout ce qui touche à
l'éducation la formation qui m'ont
vraiment passionné qui m'ont fait rester
aussi longtemps et un moment où vous
vous êtes dit il faut que je m'engage en
politique pour faire bouger aussi les
choses dans ce domaine là c'est l'étape
obligée c'est pas tout à fait comme ça
c'est à dire qu'il ya un moment où
on repart en politique de façon
associative pas pour moi c'est à dire
que j'ai intégré l'équipe de france and
was here en 2008 gelé soutenu parce
qu'il y avait un vrai un vrai projet
pour la cité je viens de versailles
maire de vallet après le projet pour la
cité qui me plaisait énormément qui me
permettait de m'engager
toujours du côté social puisque je me
suis occupé à cette époque en six ans
des sdf et des personnes qui vivaient
dans la rue et puis ensuite est arrivé
cette élection présidentielle
récente avec l'élection d' emmanuel
macron mais avant avec des forces en
présence qui pouvait être terriblement
inquiétant qui on pouvait même pensé un
deuxième tour extrême droite contre
gauche et à ce moment là je me suis
reposé sérieusement la question de dire
est ce que tu peux être utile au pays et
si tu veux être utile au pays et ce
qu'il faut engager vraiment politique ou
continuer de façon associative en
politique et j'ai tenté de passer le pas
je les passais voilà est ce ce passage
justement la mairie de versailles avec
françois de mazières bien engagement
permanent au service des plus démunis
une écoute du maire une découverte de
ceux de ce qu'est la vie municipale
d'une grande ville donc oui grand grand
moment et je suis toujours d'ailleurs
donc c'est vraiment c'est très plaisant
aujourd'hui c'est sous l'étiquette
république en marche néanmoins appliquer
ce qui a favorisé ce passage sous cette
étiquette
alors le une nouvelle approche de la
politique très différente je me suis
d'abord approché du modem en 9 en 2007
j'ai vraiment cru que françois bayrou
arrivé avec une nouvelle façon de faire
de la politique
j'ai été très vite déçu parce qu'en fait
le fonctionnement de françois bayrou
mais c'est une logique complètement
politique je vais dire un peu
provocatrice mais c'était l'extrême
centre quand on est l'extrême quelque
chose quelque part on n'écoute plus
vraiment les autres alors qu on voulait
agréger les autres chez chez emmanuel
macron j'ai senti tout de suite une
forme d'empathie et de bienveillance des
vidéos très un autre regard donc une
capacité à fédérer des gens qui arrivent
et des approches différentes de la
politique donc une logique pragmatique
et le pays doit sortir de la politique
politicienne
vous avez un regard sévère sur françois
bayrou qui pourtant s'était associé à
emmanuel macron pendant là que j'ai un
ministre et non mais je sais bien mais
c'est vrai que sur le mode sur le modem
en tant que tel sur la conception de la
rue du jard regard assez sévère oui tout
à fait
ça vous même si j'apprécie énormément
l'homme qui est un homme remarquable et
très intelligent son approche de la
politique et la même approche que tous
ceux qui font de la politique autour
voilà on évoquait tout à l'heure la
politique le cap social que vous étiez
fixés et vous le gardez les autres
membres de la commission des affaires
sociales pour le sénat est aussi membre
de la mission sur la réinsertion des
mineurs enfermés
oui ça consiste en quoi mais le sénat et
on ne le sait pas assez travaille
énormément
effet des rappeurs qui savent très
souvent à la fabrication de la loi et ce
sont des rapports qui sont construits un
peu de la même façon qu'une commission
vous avez tous les membres à tous les
partis sont représentés et nous
travaillons sur un sujet précis et donc
là c'est un sujet qui est porté à part
par notre règle par notre groupe la
république en marche par là par michel
amiel que je soutiens complètement et
c'est un sujet passionnant parce que si
on parle de prison la logique de la
prison c'est qu'on normalement au
lanceur donc on doit être capable d'être
réinsérés et malheureusement aujourd'hui
j'ai le sentiment qu'on a complètement
oublié cette cette problématique et
compense plus prison comme punition mais
qu'on n'oublie qui a ré insertion et si
on nous pousse à cette catastrophe et en
particulier chez les mineures avec une
dérive peut-être le mot était un petit
peu fort mais en tout cas leur donnant
ce de 45 depuis un certain nombre
d'années prend des coups de ciseaux qui
peuvent être très inquiétant ce travail
des dessinateurs que vous venez de
mentionner vous avez le sentiment que
dans l'opinion publique on oublie
quelquefois les sénateurs destinateur
reste une image un peu compliqué parce
qu'on est toujours en arrière alors on
travaille avec plus de temps on est on
est en recul donc effectivement on fait
moins de bruit que d'autres mais le
travail est très sérieux et il est très
apprécié mais beaucoup plus discret
c'était ce qui fait sa force
vous n'êtes pas déçu du travail qui est
mené absolument pas il est difficile
pour moi parce que je me retrouve à
représenter la majorité en étant dans
l'opposition ce qui est assez paradoxal
mais passionnant aussi puisqu'on est
humble et travailler beaucoup plus donc
le travail que nous nous faisons pour
l'arrêt mais plus compliqué puisque
nous n'avons pas la majorité mais
justement c'est de la force de
conviction permanente et donc c'est très
intéressant
apprentissage formation professionnelle
sont vos thèmes de prédilection possible
aussi aussi bien sur le bas 28 ans au
centre femmes du grand champ ali c'est
qui qui avait cette particularité
d'avoir sur aujourd'hui 2500 jeunes à
peu près 1200 étudiants 400 apprentis et
j'avais la chance depuis trois ans en
plus de mon activité secrétaire général
d'avoir pris la responsabilité du centre
de formation de grand-champ sur le pré
bac donc avec une particularité de ce
pré bac c'est qu'on allait vers les
jeunes en échec scolaire en grande
difficulté on allait récupérer dans les
missions locales en parle souvent et
notre objet c'était de leur donner ainsi
à peine deux heures permettra
d'embrasser ap ou à bac pro et surtout
de se réinsérer dans la vie sociale et
est donc aujourd'hui sat apprentissage
cette formation professionnelle au au
quotidien dans votre travail de sénateur
ça se traduit comment que je pense que
vous savez qu'on est sur une loi qui va
bientôt sortir et qui touche énormément
de l'apprentissage donc il m'a passionné
je suis totalement investi dans cette
dans cette loi je travaille beaucoup
avec la avec le ministère je travaille
beaucoup avec mes collègues j'attends
beaucoup des députés maintenant mais
c'est un travail de fond et qui me
passionne et qui correspond absolument à
ce que je pense et dont je suis très
heureux qu'on aille dans ce sens là dans
cette loi on vous sent satisfait
pleinement
pleinement satisfait de ce travail de
sénateur que vous menez aujourd'hui
quelle est votre ambition en politique
vous qui est arrivé un petit peu plus
tard resteront aucune absolument aucune
si je suis utile et je suis je suis
entré en politique pour être utile donc
si je suis utile et que j'ai servi à
quelque chose pourquoi ne pas continuer
mais mon propos aujourd'hui c'est de
servir mon pays et d'être utile à mon
pays
et après on verra bien mais je n'ai
aucune ambition particulière en
politique n'est ni sur la municipalité
de versailles alors surtout pas en
parler d'abord parce qu'on ne peut pas
cumuler déjà avant que le jeu en
question ne se pose pas et je suis
quelqu'un pour y mener une liste et puis
alors absolument parce que d'abord je
suis quelqu'un de très fidèle je
considère aussi françois nazir fait un
travail remarquable
donc en jeu j'apprécie énormément de
travailler avec lui avec son équipe qui
est très diverse et la diversité c'est
important aussi donc non donc ce sera
compliqué s'il ya une liste e république
en marche à versailles au prochain
scrutin c'est un vrai travail je pense
qu'il n'y aura pas très peu de listes
république en marche parce que il ya une
cohérence à versailles d'ouverture
d'esprit chez françois de mazières qui
est totalement compatible avec nous
peut-être que l'huître la pluie qu'on
marche qui s'est terminée par un petit
questionnaire plutôt habituels dans
cette émission
quel est votre livre de chevet là en ce
moment alors je suis sur trois livres en
même temps pour l'instant un que qui est
mon livre de chevet permanent que je
relis régulièrement c'est romain gary la
promesse de l'aube
je lis énormément de christian bobin
pour l'instant qui sont des livres
remarquables qu'ils réapprennent à
réfléchir à prendre le temps des toutes
petites phrases ciselées de façon
remarquable et un livre qui s'appelle la
fabrique des miracles d'un médecin
américain de vicky qui explique comment
à 12 ans il a été sauvé par une
rencontre d'une personne qui faisait la
méditation et qui lui a permis de
devenir un des plus grands
neurochirurgie américain alors qu'il
était condamné normalement à finir dans
dans las dans la précarité
votre film le dernier film que vous ayez
vu au cinéma où le film peut alors non
pas de cinéma c'est inquiétant pas le
temps pas eu le tord et leur musique
leur tête le le l'air qui vous restent
dans la tête en ce moment alors j'ai
pour l'instant j'écoute pas j'écoute
beaucoup france info est là et la radio
c'est un peu terrible si vous voulez
dire que les musiques ça a plutôt aidé
les chansons de type jacques brel
barbara
voilà je reste sur les classiques et les
valeurs sur les classiques les valeurs
sûres voilà un peu plus profonde merci
beaucoup marc fériés d'avoir saisi paix
à ce café politique qui merci beaucoup
[Musique]